part of the brat pack which to me is one
of the probably the coolest thing that
could ever happen to someone I'm sorry
there's only six people that could say
they're part of the prep pack I think
right
sure I'm just saying did you ever
imagine like I'm gonna be famous one day
no you know I was no I was not a wildly
confident kid at all in any kind of way
no I I just when all that happened it
was head spinning and you know but you
you forget now the broad pack is this
wonderfully iconic term with spoken with
affection and reverence for this moment
in pop culture and for a certain
generation you know I and other members
of brat back are the Avatar of their
youth you know and so it's looked at
with these rose-colored memories because
it's that's the moment in life when
people are just cusping life when
they're 20 21 when they're you know the
life life is a blank slate to be written
upon and it's get out of the way World
here I come and it's just a thrilling
exciting moment and I represent that in
other other actors do to represent that
to a certain demographic of a certain
generation but that was not the case at
the the brat package came out
the term was coined in 1985 in a New
York Magazine article by uh a guy who
was writing an article on Emilio Estevez
and took turned off to him didn't like
him and was jealous of him I'd say
because he was also a young journalist
and so he wrote this scathing article
about all these young actors and called
them the brat pack it wasn't Canby was
it no it wasn't the guy named David Blum
um
Vincent came in Houston he was another
story but
um anyway so it was a really negative
pejorative thing and we [__] hated it
and it we thought who wants hey who
wants to be called a brat who wants to
be in a pack I did a hugely it adversely
affected our careers because we were now
yeah we were now perceived as this you
know all you ever want in life is to be
seen right see me see who I am that's
what your whole thing is about this is
who I am see me and in the instant the
brat pack label came out it was like
or something we were 180 you know it
turned hard and we were members of the
Brad pack and I was unseen for like
that's
and that it's taken you know me decades
and centuries to have that go 180
degrees to embrace it as this beautiful
thing which it is now but we forget that
it wasn't at the beginning and
um you know we had I was like you know
Martin Scorsese is not going to call up
anybody in the brat pack you know and he
never did so I mean you know but so it's
been a long journey and I know for for
me and for I know the other people as
well to sort of pivot through that to
now where you know where it's landed for
me which is that that it's this sort of
this beautiful thing to represent that
for that generation of people but that
wasn't the case and it was largely just
that notion of I felt unseen suddenly
here I was just starting life just
starting my career okay here I come and
then bam no you're labeled you're
pigeonholed in this thing and this is
this is what you are from one article
which is amazing you know in our culture
now with every all the different things
it was one article one week in New York
within days the countries because it was
such a good phrase you know Brat Pack
boom yeah I mean you don't forget it's
there it's indelible